STEVE: NEW YORK NOW THE HARDEST
HIT STATE IN THE NATION WITH
MORE THAN 20,000 CONFIRMED CASES
OF THE CORONAVIRUS, AND MORE
THAN 13,000 OF THEM IN NEW YORK
CITY ALONE.
THE NATIONAL GUARD NOW BEING
DEPLOYED TO BUILD MAKE SHIFT
HOSPITALS AMID THE SURGE.
HERE WITH AN UPDATE IS NEW YORK
CITY MAYOR BILL DEBLASIO.
MAYOR GOOD MORNING TO YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU.
STEVE: WE SAW THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED OUT THIS MORNING THIS.
HE SAID THE WORLD MARKET FOR
FACE MASKS AND VENTILATORS
IS CRAZY.
WE ARE HELPING THE STATES TO GET
EQUIPMENT.
IT IS NOT THAT EASY, JUST HAD
400 VENTILATORS FOR MAYOR
DEBLASIO, WORK BEGINNING ON FOUR
HOSPITALS IN NEW YORK, MILLIONS
OF DIFFERENT ITEMS COMING.
THAT’S YOUR QUESTION ISN’T IT?
WHEN ARE THE THINGS GOING TO GET
THERE.
>> THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT, STEVE.
LOOK I’VE SPOKEN TO THE
PRESIDENT AND I APPRECIATE THAT
HE UNDERSTANDS JUST HOW CRUCIAL
IT IS TO GET THOSE VENTILATORS
TO NEW YORK CITY.
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE, STEVE,
BETWEEN SOMEONE WHO IS SUFFERING
IN ONE OF OUR HOSPITALS WHO
MIGHT MAKE IT, IF THEY HAVE THE
ACCESS TO A VENTILATOR BUT
IF WE CAN’T HAVE THEM ON A
VENTILATOR, WE COULD LOSE A LOT
OF LIVES WHO OTHERWISE COULD
PULL THROUGH, AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS TEAM IS FOCUSED ON THAT.
WE’RE GOING TO NEED A LOT.
OUR ESTIMATE IS APPROXIMATELY
15,000 BORE THIS IS OVER,
BECAUSE OF THE SHEAR GROWTH
PATTERN YOU MENTIONED.
THIS THING IS MOVING RAPIDLY AND
I THINK APRIL IS GOING TO BE A
LOT WORSE THAN MARCH AND I FEAR
THAT MAY MAY EVEN BE WORSE THAN
APRIL AND THAT’S JUST NEW YORK
CITY.
ITS THEN GOING TO BE HAPPENING
MORE AND MORE IN OTHER PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY AS WELL, AND SO
STEVE, I HAVE TO EMPHASIZE, OUR
HOSPITALS IN A MATTER OF DAYS OR
WEEKS, DEPENDING ON THE
HOSPITAL, ARE GOING TO BE
STRESSED TO THE POINT THAT THEY
CANNOT PROVIDE THE KIND OF
HEALTHCARE WE’RE USED TO, UNLESS
WE CAN GET THEM A HUGE SUPPLY OF
EQUIPMENT, SUPPLIES, PERSONNEL
AND OUR HOSPITALS BLUNTLY ARE
GOING TO START TO GO BROKE AND
THAT’S WHY ALL PARTISANSHIP
ASIDE, WHAT’S BEING TALKED ABOUT
NOW IN THE STIMULUS BILL IS
CRUCIAL, DIRECT SUPPORT FOR
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE HOSPITALS
BECAUSE IF THEY CANNOT PAY THE
BILLS AND THIS IS TRUE ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY, IF THEY CAN’T
PAY THE BILLS, HEALTHCARE WILL
DECLINE RAPIDLY, OVERALL NOT
JUST ABOUT CORONAVIRUS, OVERALL,
AND THIS IS THE THING I’M
FOCUSED ON.
WE GOT TO SURE UP OUR HOSPITALS
QUICK.
STEVE: WELL PARTICULARLY IN NEW
YORK CITY, MAYOR, BECAUSE I
HEARD DR.  BURX LAST NIGHT IN
THAT TWO HOUR LONG PRESS
CONFERENCE WITH THE PRESIDENT
SAY THAT NEW YORK CITY’S RATE OF
ATTACK IS 1 IN 1,000 WHICH IS
JAW DROPPING, THAT NEW YORK HAS
FIVE TIMES THE RATE OF INFECTION
OVER OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
SO YOU’VE GOT THIS PROBLEM AND
YOU JUST MENTIONED THAT YOU
THINK THAT APRIL AND MAY ARE
GOING TO BE REALLY BAD FOR NEW
YORK CITY, SO YOU IN ADDITION TO
THE NATIONAL GUARD, YOU’RE
THINKING MAYBE THIS SHOULD
INVOLVE A LARGER PORTION OF OUR
FEDERAL MILITARY RIGHT?
>> THAT’S RIGHT, STEVE.
LOOK I THINK THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY IS A FORCE UNLIKE ANY
IN THE WORLD IN TERMS OF ITS
ABILITY TO ORGANIZE, MOBILIZE,
DO LOGISTICS, MOVE MATERIAL ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY, AND THEY
HAPPEN TO HAVE SOME OF THE
FINEST MEDICAL PERSONNEL
ANYWHERE.
RIGHT NOW, THE EPICENTER IS IN
NEW YORK CITY BUT WE SEE IT
HAPPENING MORE AND MORE IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY YOU’RE
STARTING TO SEE FLORIDA,
LOUISIANA, GEORGIA, ALL SORTS OF
STATES ARE GOING TO GO THROUGH
THEIR WAVE NEXT.
THE ONLY FORCE I THINK THAT CAN
KEEP UP WITH THE NEED TO
CONSTANTLY MOVE SUPPLIES AND
EQUIPMENT WHERE THEY’RE NEEDED
AND DOCTORS, NURSES, OTHER
MEDICAL PERSONNEL WHERE THEY’RE
NEEDED IS GOING TO BE THE U.S.
MILITARY.
NATIONAL GUARDS ARE GREAT WITHIN
EACH STATE, BUT I THINK WE ARE
SEEING DOMINOES START TO FALL,
STEVE, THIS IS A NATIONAL CRISIS
THE ONLY PARALLEL I THINK IS NOT
ONLY THE 1918 SPANISH INFLUENZA
BUT THE GREAT DEPRESSION ITSELF
IN TERMS OF THE SHEAR NATIONAL
IMPACT INTO PEOPLE’S LIVES, AND
I THINK WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE IF
THE MILITARY IS MOBILIZED
QUICKLY, THEY ACTUALLY COULD SET
UP A STRUCTURE TO MAKE SURE
SUPPLIES GO WHERE THEY’RE NEEDED
FIRST AND THEN TRANSFERRED TO
THE NEXT STATE IN GREATEST NEED
AND THE NEXT STATE AND THE
DOCTORS AND NURSES COULD BE
MOVED AROUND, BUT THERE’S NO
OTHER FORCE IN AMERICA THAT
COULD POSSIBLY DO THAT BESIDES
OUR MILITARY.
STEVE: I KNOW THAT PETER NAVARRO
IS NOW THE POINT PERSON FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT YOU DEAL
WITH ON A DAILY BASIS AND THAT’S
GREAT, BECAUSE WE WANT ALL THE
SUPPLIES THAT ARE NEEDED BY
THE VARIOUS CITIES TO GET THEM
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE, BUT NEW
YORK IS A UNIQUE SITUATION
BECAUSE YOU’VE GOT SO MANY
PEOPLE ON THAT ISLAND AND IN THE
FIVE BOROUGHS.
IN MANHATTAN YOU GOT 28,000
PEOPLE PER SQUARE MILE.
ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT ANY OTHER
RESTRICTIONS ON PEOPLE IN THE
DAYS AHEAD JUST SO THAT THEY
HAVE A SOCIAL DISTANCE OF SIX
FEET OR  SOMETHING ELSE JUST TO
KEEP IT FROM SPREADING?
YEAH, STEVE IT’S A GREAT
QUESTION.
FIRST THING THAT I WANT TO SAY
IS I’M VERY APPRECIATIVE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP NAMED PETER
NAVARRO TO FOLLOW-UP BECAUSE
HE’S BEEN DOING AN  AMAZING JOB.
I SPOKE TO HIM MANY TIMES
YESTERDAY HE’S ALL OVER IT AND
I’M VERY THANKFUL FOR THAT.
IN TERMS OF THE QUESTION YOU ASK
, I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THE SPREAD PATTERN EVEN THOUGH
SURE, IT GETS MORE INTENSE IN A
BIG URBAN AREA LIKE THIS , I
DON’T THINK ANYBODY IN THIS
COUNTRY SHOULD REST ASSURED
THAT THERE’S NOT GOING TO BE
SPREAD IN EVERY PART OF THE
COUNTRY.
IT’S JUST THE NATURE OF THE
VIRUS AND I THINK PEOPLE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THIS IS NOT
ABOUT BLUE STATES RED STATES THE
COAST OR  THE HEARTLAND.
UNFORTUNATELY IT’S HERE IN ALL
50 STATES AND THE SMART THING WE
CAN DO IS GET  AHEAD OF IT SO TO
YOUR QUESTION LOOK IN THIS CITY,
WE HAVE THE FINEST POLICE FORCE
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD AND
COMMISSIONER SAID JUST YESTERDAY
, YOU KNOW, THEY ARE
GOING TO GO OUT AND DO WHAT THEY
DO SO WELL.
SHOW PEOPLE THE RIGHT WAY TO DO
THINGS.
COMMUNICATE WITH THE FOLKS IN
THE CITY AND SAY YOU’VE GOT TO
KEEP THAT DISTANCE.
NOW STEVE IF YOU’RE A FAMILY
LIVING UNDER THE SAME ROOF,
SOCIAL DISTANCING IS A DIFFERENT
REALITY BECAUSE YOU’RE ALREADY
IN THAT DEEP CONTACT.
IF YOU’RE GOING OUT TO THE PARK
FAMILIES ARE STAYING CLOSE
TOGETHER THAT’S FINE, BUT FOR
OTHER PEOPLE, ANYONE WHO IS
NOT FROM THE SAME EXACT FAMILY
UNIT, PEOPLE LIVING UNDER THE
SAME ROOF, WE’RE GOING TO
KEEP THAT SIX FEET APART RULE
AND NOT ALLOW ANY GATHERINGS.
I’M A GUY WHO LOVES SPORTS BUT
WE’RE NOT UNFORTUNATELY EVEN
GOING TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW TEAM
SPORTS.
WE HAVE TO KEEP PEOPLE SEPARATED
SO OUR MEN AND WOMEN OF THE  NYP
D WILL BE OUT THERE
SPREADING THE MESSAGE TELLING
PEOPLE TO BREAK IT UP, MOVE
ALONG, NO LINES TIGHT TOGETHER
IN A GROCERY STORE, NO GROCERY
STORES FULL UP.
IF WE DO THIS RIGHT AND I THINK
PEOPLE ARE GETTING IT STEVE, I
REALLY DO THINK THEY ARE HEARING
THE MESSAGE AND THE MEDIA PLAYED
A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE HERE
HELPING PEOPLE UNDERSTAND JUST
HOW SERIOUS THIS IS I THINK WE
SEE  MORE AND MORE AND OUR
POLICE COMMISSIONER SAID IT HE’S
BEEN ALL OVER THE CITY, HE SAID
HE’S SO IMPRESSED AT THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE ARE FOLLOWING THE
RULES AND I THINK THIS WEEK
EVEN MORE, SINCE WE NOW ARE
OFFICIALLY IN THIS PAUSE IN NEW
YORK STATE, LIFE IS GOING TO BE
VERY DIFFERENT BUT IF WE DO THIS
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY WE CAN
ACTUALLY SLOW THIS THING DOWN
AND KEEP OUR HOSPITALS RUNNING
AND THAT’S THE OTHER THING I
WANT TO SAY STEVE.
PEOPLE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND IF WE
DON’T KNOCK THIS THING DOWN, OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM CANNOT HANDLE
THIS STRAIN IF IT COMES ON TOO
FAST AND THAT’S JUST NOT FOR
FOLKS WITH CORONAVIRUS.
THAT’S FOR  ALL THE OTHER
HEALTHCARE CHALLENGES ALL OF THE
FOLKS WITH CANCER AND HEART
DISEASE.
WE HAVE TO PROTECT EVERYONE IN
DANGER BY KEEPING OUR HOSPITALS
GOING AND THAT MEANS THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING IS THE KEY TO SLOWING
THIS THING DOWN.
STEVE: ABSOLUTELY, AND NEW YORK
CITY IS OF COURSE AS WE’VE BEEN
TALKING AT THE EPICENTER NOW IN
THE UNITED STATES.
MAYOR DEBLASIO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE KNOW YOU GOT YOUR HANDS FULL
PLEASE COME BACK TO UPDATE US ON
WHAT YOU’RE GETTING WHAT YOU’RE
NEEDING AND HOW THE CITY OF NEW
YORK IS COPING.